sie sind ich habe es eben gerade gesagt
Präsident des Dachverbandes ne muss man
glaube ich sagen makabi 40 jüdische
Sportvereine in Deutschland ähm und ich
hab das eben schon kurz erwähnt
interessant ist und es war mir nicht
klar sie sagen wir haben mindestens
genauso viele Muslime wie Menschen
jüdischen Glaubens in diesen Verein
können Sie das einmal erklären ja also
ich bin ja gleichzeitig der Präsident
des Dachverbandes seit
2013 und schon vorher seit 2007 auch
Präsident des makabi Ortsvereins in
Frankfurt und wir in Frankfurt sind in
den letzten Jahren zum Glück entgegen
des trendes Coronas mit dem
Mitgliederzahl nach oben geschellt wir
haben mittlerweile über 4000 Mitglieder
sind in Frankfurt in einer Großstadt
Deutschlands immerhin der viertgrößte
Sportverein und wir haben 80%
nichtjüdischer Anteil bei uns in dem
jüdischen Sportverein mit dem
stilisierten Davidstern auf der Brust
laufen sie alle auf Juden Christen
Moslems interessant alle
religionszugerechtigkeiten alle
Nationalitäten und das ist erstmal per
se nichts besonderes aber bei uns läuft
man eben mit diesem stilisierten
Davidstern auf der Brust jede Woche auf
und man wird immer wieder mit den
Anfeindungen damit automatisch
konfrontiert und kommt damit darüber
auch ins Gespräch wir sensibilisieren
Leute bei uns im Sport und in der Tat
ist es auch so dass wir mittlerweile
sicherlich mindestens genauso viele
Moslims wie Juden bei uns im Verein
haben in einem jüdischen Verein in
Frankfurt in Deutschland in unserer
Gesellschaft und da sind wir richtig die
dann ihrerseits auch mit dem Davidstern
auf der Brust auflaufen genauso ist es
ja alle tragen das gleiche Trikot alle
sind in dem Moment gleich und auch Sie
werden angefeindet als Juden in erster
Linie mal weil man kein Unterschied
macht in dem Moment wo Muslim sind das
wäre genauso wie Sie Herr Land sich
jetzt komplett schwarz
ähm äh anziehen und dann im Prinzip als
schwarzer die gleichen Diskriminierung
erleiden wie jeder andere schwarze der
hier in Deutschland auf den Straßen
rumläuft oder wenn Sie eine Kipa
anziehen oder ein davidsternkette und
eine israelfage tragen mhm genuso ist es
mhm und sie sagen seit dem 7 oktober
läuft es völlig aus dem Ruder was was
heißt das so leid es mir tut aber in der
in der Tat es ist auch eine zesur hier
in Deutschland und ich bin ein großer
verfesstigter Deutschland ich liebe
schwarzrot Gold ich will mir das auch
nicht nehmen lassen von irgendwelchen
Rechten wie linken Gruppen und deswegen
freut es mich dass auch der Dachverband
makabi Deutschland von blauweiß auf
schwarzrot Gold gewechselt ist aber seit
dem 7 Oktober m ist alles von meinem
Glauben in Deutschland wirklich ein
Stück weit zusammengefallen und es fällt
mir gerade schwer mich ähm zu beraffen
und noch an das Gute zu glauben weil das
jetzt ganz ganz stark in schwanken
gerätt wenn ich hier das sehe was auf
unseren auf meinen deutschen Straßen
passiert der Land und das geht hiermit
nicht nur gegen uns Juden es geht gegen
unsere aller Gesellschaftsform gegen
alle Demokraten die hier in Deutschland
sind wir müssen aufstehen wir müssen das
erkennen dass es bei weitem und nicht
nur um die Juden geht wenn wir gerade
hier das das Trikot sehen wenn wir auf
dem Fußballplatz mal bleiben was
passiert da was erleben Sie wie hat sich
das verändert seit dem 7 Oktober na ja
es ist im Prinzip so dass ich in erster
Linie mal schon bei unseren Mitgliedern
sehr viel Überzeugungsarbeit leisten
muss dass sie ins Training kommen dass
sie am Spielbetrieb teilnehmen weil sie
sehr verunsichert sind sehr sehr sehr
viel Angst haben und noch einmal auch
sehr viele Muslime die Angst haben ihre
Kinder zu uns ins Training zu schücken
was schon inakzeptabel ist was schon
eine gewasse Art Rückzug ist wenn wir
weniger Kinder haben gucken Sie mal auch
in den jüdischen Schulen kommen immer
weniger Kinder in die
schulkass dann haben sie natürlich Leute
haben Angst ne schlicht Angst und dann
haben sie natürlich eine Situation dass
sie auf dem Fußballplatz eine Hass und
Hetz eine Gewalt Hass und hetzform
erleben und erleiden müssen die sie
vorher noch nicht hatten können Sie
einmal konkret machen was passiert dann
da mir das vorstellen sie sie sie kommen
auf den Platz und spüren wenn sie sich
nicht darauf vorbereiten und darauf sind
wir jetzt mittlerweile leider schon sehr
gut vorbereitet wenn sie sich nicht gut
vorbereiten dann kommen sie auf einen
Platz und dann werden Sie schon im
Vorfeld die Juden kommen dann merken Sie
eine angespannte Stimmung und wenn sie
es dann auch noch wagen z.B im Winter in
einer unterklassigen Mannschaft meistens
passiert es ja im Fußball können sich
vorstellen dass es eher selten beim
Schach passiert und dann 1-0 in Führung
gehen oder das Spiel knapp mit 2 Z ein
besiegen dann werden Sie nicht nur
beschimpft dann werden sie ja
handgreiflich angegriffen s dass sie
sich teilweise wirklich in den Kabinen
verstecken müssen und auf die Polizei
warten müssen damit sie ihre Mitglieder
ihre Kinder und Jugendlichen sicher nach
Hause bringen das ist der Zustand heute
in Deutschland von wem werden sie dann
angegriffen wer von den gegnerischen das
sind das sind von den gegnerischen
Mannschaften die Spielen auf GEG
meistens dann auf gegnerischen Platz
meistens dort vor den Zuschauern von den
Anhören von den Fans wir wir
identifizieren nicht genau wer das ist
weil im Endeffekt wenn wir dann die
Anzeige erstatten will niemand wissen
wer das dann gewesen ist das waren dann
die Anwohner aus den hochbausiedlungen
oder was auch immer aber im ffekt werden
attackiert und die Kinder und
Jugendliche haben Angst und die Trainer
werden auch von uns instruiert sie dann
in der Kabine einzuschließen bis dann
die Polizei kommt und eine sichere
Abfahrt gewährt ja und wi noch mal genau
verstehen worüber reden wir dann ist das
sousagen israelisch geprägt
Entschuldigung ist das arabisch geprägte
Antisemitismus oder was ist das für ein
Antisemitismus den sie da treffen also
um ehrlich zu sein Herr Land sie haben
ja selber die Muslime Platz ne ehrlich
gesagt interessiert mich das nicht was
das für einer genau ist in erster Linie
mal sondern ich kan sag
Ex das verstehe ich aber wir müssen als
Gesellschaft auch verstehen was da
passiert müssen wir müssen wir in der
Gesellschaft verstehen was passiert wenn
irgendwo im Nahen Osten ein Krieg
eskaliert dass hier Juden angefeindet
werden dass hier auf unseren Straßen der
Krieg importiert wird und Juden in dem
Fall oder irgendeine andere
Minderheit darüber oder gehetzt also
nicht Verständnis haben ne aber
verstehen finde ich müssen wir schon was
die Zusammenhänge sind das meine ich
damit na ich würde mal sagen dass wir
auf jeden Fall in erster Lin mal
erkennen müssen dass hier ein Krieg
importiert wird und wir als Gesellschaft
ähm gerade Z seehen wie das passiert und
das hinnehmen und das akzeptieren und
eben nicht aufstehen und uns dagegen
Lehen ich glaube das ist erstmal das
wichtigste und dass sich viele Menschen
die antisemitisch
aufwachsen die das nicht anders gelehrt
und gelernt bekommen haben bei uns noch
nicht und von uns noch nicht abgeholt
wurden dass wir das hier in Deutschland
nicht dlden dass wir eine andere
Gesellschaftsform eben hier mögen und
liebenm und das uns hier in Deutschland
eigentlich groß und stark gemacht hat
und das müssen wir jetzt verteidigen
Frau Tick sie sagen es kann nicht sein
dass es wieder gefährlich ist jüdisch zu
sein sie haben mehrere auch
Integrationsprojekte mit mit ähm äh
kleinen Mädchen oder oder jugendlichen
Mädchen die ähm Fußball spielen ähm wie
erleben sie das da weil das ist ja das
wenn der marmeling sagt da sind wir dann
auch ein Spiegelbild der Gesellschaft
auch auf dem Fußballplatz im
Fußballstadion da hast du sozusagen die
Projektion all der Konflikte die überall
auf der Welt stattfinden die hast du
dann plötzlich auch da wie erleben sie
das ja dem kann ich nur zustimmen
tatsächlich ist es so dass der
Fußballplatz definitiv den die
Gesellschaft widerspiegelt das bedingt
sich
gegenseitig es ist auch immer wieder ein
wechselspielt das was in der
Gesellschaft passiert trägt sich auf den
Fußballplatz und andersrum und bei
meinem ganz speziellen Projekt bei den
scoring Girls es es ja so dass ich
scoring Girl gegründet habe aus einem
Schmerz
heraus weil ich gesehen habe
was Terror Menschen antun kann weil ich
das an meiner eigenen
Religionsgemeinschaft erlebt habe und
für mich ich war zu diesem Zeitpunkt
aktive Spielerin beim ersten fC Köln und
ich war Profispielerin und Kurischen
Hintergrund ich hab Kisch jesidischen
Hintergrund genau und ich habe als
aktive Spielerin einen Schmerz erlebt
den der nicht vom Fußball kam sondern
ein Schmerz der von außen auf mich
zugetragen ist heißt heißt in meinem
Fall war der der Schmerz tatsächlich der
Genozid an meiner Religionsgemeinschaft
3000 km weit entfernt an den Jesiden
wofür sich durch den is durch den
islamischen Staat für den sich niemand
interessiert hat und ich als aktive
Spielerin zu dieser Zeit beim ersten fC
Köln konnte als ich vom Platz runter
gegangen bin gar nicht anders damit
umgehen als der Schmerz ist so auf mich
eingeprasselt diese Gefühle diese
Emotionen und ich habe mich alleine
gefühlt ich habe mich hilflos gefühlt
und ich habe dann aber dieses Mittel des
Sports nicht dafür genutzt um hat Hass
und Hetze zu verbreiten sondern ich habe
es eben genutzt um
für ein Engagement genutzt indem ich
dann eben scoring Girls gegründet habe
ein ein ein Projekt welches sich an
geflüchtete mädchenet genau vielleicht
können wir ein paar Bilder aus der Regie
mal zuspielen mal zu verstehen was sie
da machen sie machen das auch glaube ich
zum Teil in in Flüchtlingslager wenn ich
das richtig im Kopf habe im Irak im Irak
genau ich das ist aber erstmal hier in
Köln was Sie hier sehen genau das ist in
Köln wir sind in Köln dreimal wir sind
haben vier Standorte in Berlin wir sind
aber auch mit drei standen Orten im Irak
selbst so und und sie sie sagen da gibt
es Mädchen die haben zum Teil
Familienangehörige in Gaza äh die die
kommen aus
aus dem Westjordanland die kommen aus
den palästinensischen Flüchtlingslagern
die seit Jahrzehnten mittlerweile gibt
und so weiter das heißt dieser Schmerz
ihr Schmerz den sie damals gefühlt den
haben sie da jetzt auch wieder haben wir
da auch und deswegen ist es total
wichtig und da muss man auch also wir
müssen die Menschen auch in ihrem
Schmerz abholen wir müssen sensibel sein
wir müssen empathisch sein und wir
können aber auch von diesen Menschen
verlangen dass sie in Trauer gehen
können ohne dabei antisemitisch zu sein
ohne dabei
beispielsweise zu fordern die
Vernichtung Israels zu fordern wie in
einigen Posts passiert und ich glaube es
ist sehr sehr wichtig was ich mit meiner
tagtäglichen Arbeit und mit meinen mit
Mitarbeiterin tagtäglich tue ist ja
genau das aufzufangen das heißt wir
öffnen diesen Raum wir nutzen scoring
Girls in diesem Moment weil die Mädels
auch auf uns zukommen wir haben
muslimische Mädchen wir haben
christliche Mächen wir haben jüdische
Mädchen wir haben arabische kurdische
türkische Mädchen wir haben alles
was bei uns mitspielt und aus über 15
Nationen und natürlich haben sie Ängste
und natürlich haben sie sorgen und
dieser Konflikt der dort entsteht der
ist ja schon längst hier in Deutschland
angekommen das ist ja nicht etwas was
was nur dort stattfindet sondern es
findet auch hier auf diesen straßenstadt
und es ist für mich wichtig als
Gründerin von den scoring Girls den Raum
aufzumachen um die Ängste die Sorgen die
Fragen auch dieser jungen Mädchen
aufzugreifen und sie zu begleiten und
wir reden über Antisemitismus wir reden
über antimuslimischen Rassismus wir
reden aber wir gehen aber auch in die
Begegnung wir gehen in die Begegnung wir
gehen Dialoge wir ich glaube dass es
auch ganz ganz wichtig ist dass wir in
diese Begegnung gehen dass wir dafür
sorgen dass Menschen sich austauschen
denn was dieser Konflikt ja auch zeigt
ist dass sich sehr viele Jugendliche vor
allem alleine fühlen genau was was wir
auch hier in der Sendung und was ich
auch sonst häufig mitkriege ist gerade
auf der ich sag's jetzt mal ganz platt
die auf der palästinensischen Seite ja
auf der anderen Seite sozusagen da gibt
es ein Gefühl von ihr seht unseren
Schmerz nicht ihr hört uns nicht
wirklich zu ihr
versteht nicht wirklich dass das was mit
uns gerade passiert sie atmen einmal
tief durch ja ich muss wirklich tief
durchatmen ich bitte auch um
Entschuldigung dass ich sie jetzt nicht
ganz Ausreden lasse schon beginnt mit
dieser anderen Seite warum ist das eine
andere Seite warum definiert man das
immer mit andere Seite es ist doch die
gleiche Seite wir haben doch überhaupt
gar kein Problem oder ihr und wir es ist
kein ihr und wir es sind die Werte die
wir Teil wo ist kein i und wir nein
warum weil die andere Seite die
palästinensische Seite warum ist das die
andere Seite warum können wir nicht eine
gemeinsame gich ich artiuliere und
ventiliere nur ein ein Gefühl dass es da
draußen in dieser Gesellschaft sehr
massiv gibt und ich kann ih nur sagen
ich könnte ihn aus unzähligen
Zuschriften auch zitieren und die Leute
sagen bitte ih ihr müsst versuchen
möglichst auch beide Seiten deswegen
rede ich dann auch so AbZ aber die
laufen nicht konträr beide Seiten das
ist ja die Frage die Frage ist immer die
auch mein könen sofort drauf einigen
wenn wir sagen die Hamas ist eine
Heimsuchung nicht nur für für Israel
sondern auch eine Heimsuchung für die
Menschen in Gaza K man uns sofort drauf
einigen Israels oder der Palästinenser
stehen ich kann auch auf beiden Seiten
diese Kinder haben nee und trotzdem geht
es s muss ich ihm aber recht geben es
geht tatsächlich nicht darum es
jedes jedes palästinensische zivile
Opfer in Gaza ist eines zu viel genauso
wie jedes Opfer des 7 oktober eines zu
viel war ja und wir müssen aufhören von
Leuten zu verlangen oder zu fragen auf
welcher Seite stehst du
e
sage nur ich weiß aber da draußen da
draußen wird die diese Frage gestellt
sie wird gestellt da da da diese fr
diese Fragen werden gestellt und wir
müssen aufhören die Frage zu stellen auf
welcher Seite stehst du sondern es geht
am Ende des Tages darum dass wir
natürlich ganz klar von Terror sprechen
müssen von einer Terrororganisation der
Hamas sprechen müssen wir aber
gleichermaßen auch sagen können und
müssen dass es aber nicht sein kann dass
jetzt wieder antisemitische Parolen ähm
durch die Straßen Deutschlands
gehen und dennoch sage ich auch dass es
immer immer und das ist Teil meiner
Arbeit so sind ist unsere
Menschenrechtsarbeit gegründet h help so
sind die scoring Girls gegründet dass es
darum geht in die Verbindung zu gehen
und nicht in die Spaltung und und und
noch mal ganz kurz zu Ihrer Frage warum
man ob man die andere Seite nicht
versteht ich weiß gar nicht wer das
erzählt das stimmt doch gar nicht man
sieht doch auch das Leid der
Palästinenser und man sieht auch und wo
wenn nicht in Israel wird so ein Thema
so heiß diskutiert dass es auf jeden
Fall innerhalb der Regierung eine
Veränderung geben muss also wo ich weiß
nicht wo hier in Deutschland fehlt es an
Unterstützung an die palästinensische
Organisationen Hilfsorganisation sei es
in finanzieller in persönlichen
Ansprachen in Reisen das ist doch ein
amenmärchen das stimmt doch gar nicht
die Unterstützung gibt es und ich würde
mich freuen über jede Demonstration die
es auf deutschen Straßen gibt die
friedlich redlich fürde sich die für die
Palästinenser ähm ähm äh ausgibt aber
dem ist ja nicht so das ist ja nicht das
was auf unseren Straßen eben skandiert
und gerufen wird sondern auf diesen
angeblichen proalästinensischen
Demonstrationen und das ist eben der
riesen Unterschied wird Hass und Hetz
gegen Juden skandiert und dann gibt es
und dann frage ich die andere Seite wenn
Sie möchten weil das ist wirklich eine
andere Seite die so etwas skandiert die
sehe ich als andere Seite das ist
Antidemokraten und das sind keine
Muslime in meinen Augen das sind
Fundamentalisten das sind Islamisten
denn die Muslime die die ich kenne und
ich kenne sehr viele die denken nicht so
aber und den Vorwurf frage ich mal hier
in die Runde wo sind die denn warum
werden die nicht lauter in ihren eigenen
Communities warum weil sie Angst haben
weil sie genauso viel Angst haben wie
viele andere hier in Deutschland Moment
bitte lass mich zu Ende führen weil wir
alle hier viel zu viel Angst haben und
was passiert dann wir ziehen uns zurück
und wenn wir von nie wieder reden dass
wir viel zu lange geschwiegen haben viel
zu lange leise dann sind wir jetzt
wieder leise wieder viel zu leise und
ziehen uns zurück und das der größte
Fehler den wir machen können denn das
haben wir aus unserer deutschen
Vergangenheit doch gelernt leise sein
und sich zurückziehen ist der größte
Fehler weil wir dann diesen angeblichen
rechten und linken die denken sie werden
in der Mehrheit den freien Lauf lassen
wir überlassen den das Spielfeld das
dürfen nicht machen wir müssen lauter
werden her
l will nur noch mal sagen und dafür
plädiere ich
sehr wir sind ja auch jetzt in in der
wie vielten Woche auch immer seit dem 7
Oktober
es ist schon auch wichtig klar zu zu
differenzieren also mir war das jetzt
eben zu pauschal zu sagen so findet das
nicht statt da gibt es nur Judenhass auf
deutschen Straßen wir haben in dieser
Sendung sehr sehr klar benannt was auf
den Straßen in Essen passiert ist vor
ein paar Wochen
das wurde teilweise deklariert als
proalästinensische Demonstration da bin
ich total bei es war keine
propalestinensische Demonstration
sondern da waren Flaggen zu sehen die
sahen aus wie und das sollte auch so
sein wie isfaggen da waren Islamisten
Fundamentalisten keine netten Menschen
unter wegs gar keine Frage aber es gibt
natürlich auch die anderen
Demonstrationen auf die ich auch noch
mal klar hinweisen will äh und dort wird
einfach dann im Zweifel tatsächlich für
Palästina demonstriert das ist
Demonstrationsrecht das ist auch völlig
in Ordnung und das darf in diesem Land
auch stattfinden und das passiert auch
und findet auch auf dem Boden des
Grundgesetzes statt
und wenn dann dort etwas kritisiert wird
dann ist es israelische Politik und auch
das ist in Ordnung auch das darf
stattfinden Herr Schul muss genau
richtig sehen auch viele Israelis üri